خصصت هارس افتتاحيتها للدعوه لوقف قتل
الصحفيين الفلسطينيين وتحديدا في قطاع غزه
واستهلت الصحيفه افتتاحيتها بسرد ما تعرض
له مراسل قناه الجزيره البارز كما وصفتها
وائل الدحدوح قائله انه تحول الى رمز في
اسرائيل يفضلون عرض الصحفيين الغزيين على
انهم اعضاءهم في حماس او مؤيدون للارهاب
تقول الصحيفه بينما يراهم سائر الع صحفيين
يخاطرون بحياتهم ويعملون في ظروف مستحيله
لنقل حقيقه ما يجري في غزه حيث تغيب
الصحافه
الاجنبيه يعتبر مقال في صحيفه اسرائيل
هيوم التصعيد بين اسرائيل وحزب الله نتيجه
منطقيه بعد العديد من الاغتيالات التي
نسبت لاسرائيل ويرى ان المشكله التي تواجه
اسرائيل حاليا هي الوعد الذي قطعته لسكان
المناطق الشماليه المتمثل في ضمان عوده
امنه الى منا زلهم يرجح المقال جنوح
اسرائيل الى محاوله التوصل الى تفاهم مع
حزب الله لجلب الهدوء الى المناطق
الحدوديه لكنه يستبعد قدرتها على ابعاد
تهديده في وقت قريب صحيفه النيويورك تايمز
نشرت مقالا يشرح كيف تسبب هجوم حماس في
احداث ضرر كبير في قطاع التكنولوجيا في
اسرائيل وينقل عن خبراء توقعاتهم بان يزيد
الاختلال في نشاط شركات التكنولوجيا من
تباطؤ الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي ويحذر من ان
التهديد الاخر يكمن في تراجع الاستثمار
الاجنبي بعد هجوم السابع من اكتوبر سلطت
لوفيغارو الضوء على نتائج تقييم لحجم
الدمار في غزه وجد ان عدد المباني التي
دمرت او تضررت من القصف الاسرائيلي قد
تجاوز 160 ال حسب الصحيفه يظهر من التقييم
الذي استند موه الى صور الاقمار الصناعيه
ان الضرر الاكبر يتركز في القسم الشمالي
للقطاع لكنه نبه الى ان مناطق في الجنوب
الذي يستمر فيه القتال تشهد يوميا عددا
متزايدا من المباني
المدمره تحدث تقرير في صحيفه لوموند حول
اولى جلسات الاستماع في الشكوى التي تقدمت
بها جنوب افريقيا ضد اسرائيل امام محكمه
العدل الدوليه قائلا ان الاجراء بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين في غزه فرصه لتسليط الضوء على
المحنه التي يعيشونها منذ بدايه القصف
الاسرائيلي خصوصا بعد الياس من قدره الدول
الغربيه على فرض وقف اطلاق نار على
حليفتها
اسرائيل